welcome back he is known as mr las vegas
for a reason he started performing here
when he was just 15 years old he first
came here with his brother though before
he went solo
wayne newton says it hasn't always been
easy he loves this town here's what he
had to say about becoming a headliner
here
what does vegas mean to you what do the
people here mean to you vegas means
everything to me this is the greatest
city in the world the people
in this town
took us in as kids
made sure we didn't get in trouble
didn't go down the wrong path
didn't go to any of frank sinatra's
parties
uh and
have have shown up
when i opened the flamingo
myself
as a headliner
there were beds up and down the strip in
those days there were seven hotels on
the strip
and uh
they had a little bet going about how
fast i was gonna die
and um
meaning the show not so well right not
me ending up in lake mead
and not only did
the show succeed but we sent all kind of
records for that time of year
in las vegas still setting records so
coming up in about 25 minutes wayne is
going to talk about how his brother quit
the act
up in the middle of the night and then
what happened next so
uh glad he didn't end up in lake mead
he's done very well for himself here 65
years on stage not him dying for the
show he was glad
we're glad he didn't die too all right
he is so fun and it's time for another
wayne newton giveaway wayne himself has
autographed a few things for viewers and
fans today we're giving away one of his
own red hankies right there you see him
signing it along with the hanky this
prize also includes an autographed photo
of wayne like the one you see right
there
he always does that with his tie like
little